mohamed des ménages en transportant le
canapé du salon
le déménageur l'eshop à le canapé et
sérieusement endommagé
l'entreprise de déménagement accepte de
le dédommager haut mais pas complètement
parce qu'aux contrats il est écrit que
le client doit payer les premiers 250
dollars pour toutes réclamations à la
suite d'un bris un mohamed doit-il
accepter non la loi prévoit faire
commerçant ne peut dans un contrat
miniter sa responsabilité
même si mohamed a signé le contrat la
clause est invalide
il peut donc exiger que son déménageur
paye la réparation en entier non
déménageurs refuse l'aide devra
poursuivre devant les tribunaux
il peut aussi déposer une plainte à
l'office de la protection du
consommateur
l'office pour intenter une poursuite
contre le déménageur cette rose à une
amende
un mode histoire un contrat c'est un
contrat mais une clause illégal c'est
illégal